para construir una empresa aeroespacial y una base de despegue,
pero cada vez que se lanza un cohete
hay que cercar alrededor de 2000 km de espacio aéreo
y 2000 km de espacio marítimo de transporte.
Curiosamente, es una de las cuestiones que EE. UU. no gestiona bien,
porque cuando se cerca todo ese espacio aéreo
se altera el viaje de muchos pasajeros que intentan llegar a su destino.
Las aerolíneas detestan a las empresas aeroespaciales
porque les supone un gasto de unos EUR 62 500 por minuto.
Lo que se necesita para tener un acceso inmediato al espacio,
un acceso seguro y frecuente,
es una pequeña nación insular en medio de la nada,
sin vecinos y sin tráfico aéreo.
Y resultó ser Nueva Zelanda.
(Risas)
Esa es la parte relativa a la infraestructura.
Lo siguiente es la normativa.
Lo crean o no, Nueva Zelanda no es famosa por su dominio espacial,
o al menos no lo era.
Y no se puede equipar a un país
con lo que se considera un misil balístico de largo alcance
porque, por desgracia, si se puede poner un satélite en órbita,
puede usarse para hacer cosas muy peligrosas.
De pronto, uno se enfrenta a un montón de normas y reglamentos
y a los tratados internacionales
de no proliferación de armas de destrucción masiva y demás.
Resulta bastante complejo.
Para hacer el lanzamiento en Nueva Zelanda,
tuvimos que hacer que los gobiernos de EE. UU. y Nueva Zelanda
accedieran a la firma de un tratado bilateral.
Y cuando se firmó ese tratado bilateral para salvaguardar la tecnología,
el gobierno de Nueva Zelanda asumió muchas responsabilidades
y tuvo que elaborar un sinfín de normas y reglamentos:
tuvo que aprobar leyes por medio del Parlamento y de un comité selecto,
en última instancia, hasta concretar las leyes.
Y cuando hay leyes, es necesario administrarlas,
así que creó una agencia espacial.
Y una vez que lo hizo,
los australianos se sintieron excluidos y crearon una agencia espacial.
y así sucesivamente.
Como ven, una gran parte de todo esto, de hecho, dos terceras partes,
ni siquiera tiene que ver con cohetes.
(Risas)
Hablemos de cohetes.
Lo que no he mencionado es que tenemos licencia
para hacer lanzamientos cada 72 horas en los próximos 30 años.
Tenemos más disponibilidad de lanzamiento como empresa privada
que los EE. UU. en su totalidad.
Y un lanzamiento cada 72 horas
significa que hay que construir un cohete cada 72 horas.
Y, por desgracia, no existe algo como un servicio integral para cohetes.
No se pueden comprar piezas para construir un cohete.
Cada cohete está hecho totalmente a medida.
Cada pieza está hecha totalmente a medida.
Es una lucha continua con la física todos los días.
Todos los días libro una batalla con la física.
Y les pondré un ejemplo de ello:
en el lateral de nuestro cohete hay una franja plateada.
Esto es porque hay piezas de aviónica ahí detrás.
Debíamos reducir la emisividad de la superficie
para evitar que las piezas se quemaran con la luz del sol,
y pintamos una franja plateada.
Por desgracia, al atravesar la atmósfera de la Tierra
se genera mucha electricidad estática,
y sin la pintura conductora se enviarían descargas a la Tierra.
Incluso la pintura plateada debe ser triboelectrificada,
certificada, aplicada y demás;
por no hablar de las placas adhesivas...
Hasta la cosa más simple es siempre una auténtica batalla.
El núcleo de cualquier lanzadera espacial es el motor.
Este es nuestro motor de cohete Rutherford.
Por lo general, los motores de los cohetes
se evalúan en función del tiempo de producción,
meses o incluso a veces años, en los motores de gran tamaño.
Pero con lanzamientos cada 72 horas y con 10 motores por cohete,
es necesario fabricar motores de forma rápida.
Tuvimos que idear un nuevo método y ciclo para el motor del cohete.
Creamos un nuevo ciclo llamado turbobomba eléctrica,
pero también conseguimos imprimir los motores de cohete en 3D.
Cada uno de estos motores se imprime en 3D en una superaleación de inconel,
y ya podemos imprimir alrededor de un motor cada 24 horas.
El ciclo de la turbobomba eléctrica es un modo totalmente distinto
de bombear el propulsor en el motor del cohete.
Cargamos cerca de un megavatio en la batería de a bordo
y obtenemos mini turbobombas eléctricas, del tamaño de una lata de Coca-Cola,
no mucho más grandes.
Giran a 42 000 RPM,
y cada una de esas turbobombas
genera la misma potencia que un coche familiar promedio.
Nuestro cohete tiene 20 turbobombas.
Como ven, algo tan simple como el bombeo de propulsor
produce quebraderos de cabeza.
Este es Electron, ¡y funciona!
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
No solo una vez, lo hace con cierta frecuencia,
algo útil con muchos clientes a los que poner en órbita.
Hasta ahora, hemos puesto 25 satélites en órbita.
Y lo mejor de todo es que podemos hacerlo con una gran precisión.
De hecho, ubicamos los satélites con un radio de precisión de 1,4 km.
Supongo que, si van en taxi, 1,4 km no es un radio de precisión alto,
pero en términos espaciales, equivale a unos 180 milisegundos.
Atravesamos 1,4 km en unos 180 milisegundos.
La verdad es que es bastante difícil.
(Risas)
Voy a hablarles ahora de la basura espacial.
Ya he hablado a lo largo de la charla
de cómo nos proponemos hacer lanzamientos cada 72 horas,
y todo lo demás.
Pero no quiero pasar a la posteridad
como el tipo que puso en órbita la mayor cantidad de basura espacial.
Ese es el gran secreto de la industria.
La mayoría de la gente ignora
que una gran parte del total de la basura espacial
no son satélites, sino restos de cohetes.
Porque para ascender a órbita hay que expulsar partes del cohete,
con la batalla de la física.
Voy a mostrarles un poco de mecánica orbital básica
y a explicar cómo llegamos a órbita
y cómo nuestra forma de hacerlo difiere mucho del resto.
En el transcurso de la segunda etapa
se separa una pieza de la parte superior, llamada "kick stage",
pero esta etapa permanece en una órbita altamente elíptica.
Y en el perigeo de la órbita, o el punto más bajo,
penetra en la atmósfera de la Tierra y es propulsada hacia arriba.
Lo que queda es la "kick stage",
la pieza blanca en la parte inferior de la pantalla.
Tiene su propio sistema de propulsión,
usado para elevar y ajustar la órbita y luego desplegar el vehículo espacial.
Como tiene su propio motor, lo ponemos en una órbita retrógrada,
lo reubicamos en una órbita altamente elíptica,
lo reintroducimos en la atmósfera y lo propulsamos hacia arriba,
y no queda ningún rastro.
El resto de la industria es francamente repugnante,
deja su basura por todos lados.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Voy a contarles una pequeña anécdota que revelará mi edad:
fui a un colegio en el límite meridional de la Isla Sur de Nueva Zelanda,
un colegio pequeño,
y teníamos un ordenador parecido a este.
Conectada al ordenador había una pequeña caja llamada módem
y cada viernes, la clase se reunía junto al ordenador
y enviábamos un correo a otro colegio en EE. UU.
con el mismo tipo de configuración,
y ellos enviaban un correo de vuelta.
Nos parecía algo totalmente increíble.
Muchas veces me pregunto qué pasaría si retrocediera en el tiempo
y me contara a mí mismo todo lo que llegaría a ocurrir
debido a esa pequeña caja conectada al ordenador.
Lo vería como una fantasía.
Y la realidad es que es justo donde nos encontramos con respecto al espacio.
Estamos a punto de democratizar el espacio,
y acabamos de enviar nuestro primer correo electrónico al espacio.
Les pondré algunos ejemplos:
el año pasado, lanzamos un pequeño satélite
construido por un grupo de estudiantes de secundaria.
Estudiaban la atmósfera de Venus.
Un grupo de estudiantes que lanzaban su propio satélite.
Otro buen ejemplo:
hay un gran número de proyectos muy importantes ahora mismo
para poner en órbita grandes constelaciones de pequeños satélites
para que Internet llegue a cada milímetro cuadrado del planeta.
Algo muy útil para muchos de los que están en esta sala
porque nos permite ver Netflix donde queramos.
Pero si se piensa en los países menos desarrollados,
es una forma de difundir todo el conocimiento que tenemos
a todo el mundo.
Y eso tendrá un impacto muy significativo.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)